[Musique]
je crois que ça fait partie de notre
rôle que d'aller vers les gens donc je
pense qu'il faut absolument communiquer
la fête de la science est un bon exemple
de communication vers les jeunes alors
peut-être dans la Fête de la Science moi
vers politique si possible vers le grand
public c'est toujours assez difficile
mais j'ai toujours considéré que que
disons communiquer nos résultats les
faire savoir alors c'est important de le
faire aussi au sein de notre communauté
de rédiger des articles scientifiques
mais il faut absolument aussi mettre ses
résultats je dirais à porter de tous les
publics
ce qui m'intéressait c'est de faire
comprendre en quoi l'étude des climats
passés nous apporter des informations
très pertinentes pour l'évolution future
du climat je me suis intéressé disons
bien sûr je suis beaucoup impliqué dans
le GIEC je me suis beaucoup impliqué
dans les dans toutes les conventions
climat j'ai participé depuis 20 ans donc
à travers cette histoire on peut
effectivement et c'était le l'objectif
de la documentariste raconter la prise
de conscience et je crois que c'est le
fil rouge de la prise de conscience de
la réalité de réchauffement climatique
et c'est ça je crois l'intérêt de ce
documentaire
l'action c'est aujourd'hui et donc les
jeunes qui rentrent vous êtes aussi
concernés par l'action à la fois par
l'inaction et par l'action et voilà et
moi j'encourage mais c'est vrai pour
toutes les générations à l'action aussi
bien dans la vie
on a de l'action dans sa vie je dirais
de citoyens ça vide tous les jours quand
on regarde la recommandations de
citoyens se déplaçaient se nourrir se
loger c'est notre vie de tous les jours
mais aussi je pense sincèrement pour
tous les jeunes qui s'engagent dans le
monde du travail et bien il y a pas de
secteurs d'activité qui puisse se dire
que le réchauffement climatique ce n'est
pas son affaire
[Musique]